On a aussi des idées à défendre.
On a aussi des combats à mener.
On a des choses à faire.
On a envie de faire bouger les lignes,
tout simplement.
Bonjour, je suis Arthur Billot,
je suis président
des Jeunes Démocrates
de Bourgogne-Franche-Comté.
Parallèlement à ça,
je suis aussi étudiant
en science politique.
J'ai adhéré au Mouvement Démocrate
à l'âge de 16 ans.
C'est d'abord un engagement européen,
ensuite, celui-ci a été complété
par la logique libérale,
par l'humanisme,
par finalement
tout cet engagement là
qui prend corps en ce parti.
Plus largement,
c'est aussi un groupe d'amis.
C'est aussi un lien social,
c'est une logique politique
qui permet de s'ancrer sur le terrain,
de découvrir son territoire.
J'ai été élu président
des Jeunes Démocrates
de Bourgogne-Franche-Comté
lors de la convention régionale du MoDem.
Ce qui m'a d'abord intéressé
dans cette idée-là,
de reprendre cette fédération,
c'est sûrement,
je pense,
de créer un collectif,
un collectif de jeunes engagés
qui ont envie
d'apporter quelque chose à la cité.
Pour ça, on a plein d'esprit,
on a une pluralité de talents
à faire émerger, mais aussi à consolider.
Moi, c'est d'abord
cette logique assez humaine qui m'a plu.
Quand je pense à cette logique humaine,
je pense à cette logique humaniste,
qui relève plutôt des idées.
On a aussi des idées à défendre,
mais aussi des combats à mener.
On a des choses à faire,
on a envie de faire bouger les lignes,
tout simplement.
Je pense que ce volontarisme
est d'abord clé.
Il faut penser en termes d'engagement,
en termes d'impact, de militantisme.
Au-delà de ça,
on a aussi une fédération à restructurer,
on a des échéances qui arrivent assez vite,
des engagements
à prendre, des défis à relever.
Une fédération
des Jeunes Démocrates, pour moi,
c’est une fédération
qui est plurielle.
On doit pouvoir collaborer
avec les fédérations aînées du MoDem
dans tous les départements,
c'est-à-dire qu’on doit être une force de soutien,
on doit être capable justement
d'apporter de l'aide
quand il y en a besoin.
Mais pas seulement,
on doit aussi être un collectif de jeunes
qui s'engagent,
qui cherchent aussi
à accomplir certaines choses,
à déverrouiller certaines problématiques.
C'est justement cette dualité
qui est intéressant dans une fédération
de Jeunes Démocrates.
On a d'une part
l'engagement partisan
au sens
vraiment local et en même temps,
on a ce côté assez humain
quand on se retrouve tous ensemble,
on prend des verres,
on partage des moments ensemble
et mis bout à bout, on arrive justement à
une continuité, un engagement
qui s’ancre sur la durée
dans lequel justement, les gens
peuvent s'épanouir.